And once again, thank you very much for the
invitation. I can tell you that the
Nevada Promises Scholarship was created in
2017 and it is a law that is very similar to the
Millennium
Scholarship. This particular scholarship is supposed
to help people or
students.  from high school so that
when they apply to university,
ball college and high school so they
can go to school and almost without paying
anything out of pocket then and as
I told you snow will promise to create in 2007 and
we are in all
high schools not only for  the south of
elevated or las vigas but it is a scholarship that
is for the whole state that basically
unites us to all the
community schools as if they are already in the south
but they also have yes yes double the
also yes and to tbc which are
community schools in the  state and it's
important to say that because each and every
one of our schools has certain
majors or majors
and that maybe appeal to
certain students that we're hot  and
outside of the state, so we want to
keep the talented students
here in Navarra because we need them,
that's how I tell you, this scholarship comes
from our taxes, so it's
important for the community, as I
tell you, to support these students in every way
so that our
money is also a good investment
basically that the student
finishes school but also finishes
that the students of the rules
want to go to university what they don't
have is the money to do it
so through our scholarship if it is  that
the student applied for
financial aid and the government gave them
let's say loans gave them maybe a
little bit of money to work at
berwick start iii college but it didn't give them
enough money to pay for their
tuition for their books well it will snow
forms help with that  If the government did not
give you enough money, it will take promises that it
would pay what it is
and certain costs that are state requirements.
Given what you have to pay, and in
that sense, it would help you alleviate the
high cost of going to university. There
is this benefit that lasts two years and
three years as long as the
student remains eligible and as long as
the student remains eligible once you
arrive.  either in the first semester they
basically have to do eight hours
of community service they have to
meet or talk with a mentor
that we are going to introduce them to
at least once before
June 1, 2021 the student has to
apply for admissions to a  of the
community schools in this case for
us it would be that if they do the
student has to do a
training they will have the
requirement and for us if they
do it is the orientation of
new students who are on the internet
and once the student completes
all this
they have to sign up for
football the fall
right after they graduate
high school so they're getting in  They
are very eager and they have to take 12
credits for college this semester and
222 and credits have to count for
a university degree, they can take
any class, even so, what we
want to do is focus on the student
who is looking for the degree they like and who
focus and finish as I told you the
student there has to continue
talking with their mentors at
least once a semester they have to
do eight hours of community service
every semester exactly during the summer and
maintain their grades at
least 2.0 which would be  a gray one from unace to
keep the scholarship until the end
until three years or graduation the scholarship
cannot be transferred to the university
let's say I didn't see they have to
finish using them
in the funds at our school or
transfer to another school  two years old
so they are important points that
we want to share with the public now
all we need right now
we have five thousand studies  before they were
recruited and by the year 2021 2022 which is
obviously going to start school
next year in the fall these kids
are not in high school right now they are finishing high school we
need 450 mentors to
be able to help these
five  thousands of students to enter
college with this exact criminal scholarship,
for example, we would pay for that
and it also has to be obvious a
training that is quite fast
where we tell them about how
our scholarship works and what
students have to do and  We also
give them tips on how to guide them
through the school, no, and once that
happens, we wait until the month of March. The
student is already completely and
applied for financing, he is already
in the seats, and we can make them
start the relationship.  an email
to the online german student the student's parent
and mentor for
me to communicate can have a
conversation through a zoo  m a
zoom call or it can be google meet it
can be any of the
remote options right now because
obviously we want them to keep
their distance
but in the future they may meet they
decide to have a coffee and not continue
that relationship in the future but for now
what we want is for it not to be
and people in the community don't
give us their time and we are in an
age of Christmas season where people
are looking for a way to be part of
something important and it seems to me that Navarra
Promise or this promise  What are we
doing to our
youth that things are going to get
better and that they have opportunities? We
need their time to make that
a reality.